welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about how to wish
away your boss at work so that you can
finally have casual friday every day of
the week every single day
can you imagine seeing all of your
co-workers calf muscles every day of the
week like heaven heaven on earth my name
is um show off them legs show them up
let me see them legs that's what i was
made to stop people like me from getting
pretty much pretty much
my name is mt and i'm here today with
off-screen producer brandon what's going
on brandon
hello mt so glad to be back i'll be q
with you my friend glad to be boys i
missed you bad i love doing it's been a
minute it's been a minute it's been a
little bit of a minute but now we're in
a new minute a new minute of mystery and
questions what's our big question up for
today brandon well mt the latest entry
into the mcu thor love and thunder
introduced us to the villain known as
gore and he had one goal in mind getting
rid of all of the gods uh not an easy
feat to do
only one by one right that's a lot of
work but our butcher had found the cheat
code all he had to do was make it to the
being known as eternity and wish away
all those gods but thor mighty thor and
valkyrie all stood in his way stop
prevented gore from ultimately making
his wish you saw the movie but
what if they weren't able to stop him
that all leads us to this week's big
question which actually came from our
amazing editor alexa thank you alexa
what would happen if gore had succeeded
and killed all of the gods
[Music]
while wiping out all the gods in the mcu
would certainly fix a lot of problems
you can be certain that the removal of
these divine deities would also create a
whole new set of issues in the delicate
and vast ecosystem of the multiverse so
let's try and break down what the
implications would be for an mcu that
suddenly found itself without gods and
we'll start from the bottom and work our
way up to the up the holy food chain
shall we brandon
oh like we should let's let's break down
these gods
jesus zeus living too loud i'm gonna
take you down a pig all right just
kidding uh
well let's start with the gods of earth
which is you know a lot a lot of gods
this brings up our first question
what would we consider a god because
most of earth gods are aliens from other
planets or dimensions so if we're going
to go through this right mt i think if a
god
is someone or something that's
definitely worshipped right i think you
have to have followers to be a god or at
least you have some some some ultimate
like control or power maybe i think a
lot of it is just having like worshipers
right because you're right a lot of our
gods are just like aliens powerful
aliens right i feel like a lot of um
well at least the implication i got from
moon knight is that like it really all
comes down to like how many people are
worshiping you and how many people are
actively
thinking about like this active god and
also
um like how much cosmic energy i feel
like a god possesses yeah i feel like is
also true a huge um contributor to
what makes a god a god having a lot of
people believe in you i think like we we
know from like the the duo like all of
that had to do with
someone's like your beliefs and like
what you your consciousness and like
what your consciousness mainly believed
while you lived so like
yeah i feel like there's some type of
connection there right because like we
wouldn't call all of the asgardians gods
right but just like thor
and loki
and odin and frigate those are gods but
not all of the asgardians are god's even
though they're all stronger than humans
and they're like more powerful they're
not all gods because they don't have
like all that cosmic energy they don't
have
worshipers just the ones that like we're
worshiping or like being followed those
are the gods that's what we'll consider
god's here but then gore completes his
wish and now all the gods of earth are
gone
be gone such that means no more norse
gods olympians or even the indian who we
just met so no more thor valkyrie it's
anybody because they're all gone yeah so
because valkyrie is a guy do we consider
valkyrie a god or is valkyrie i mean
she's gotta be i mean she's like she's
the queen god of gods she's the new
asgard king
right okay she's
i think we would consider her a god
she's like are all the valkyries though
would they be considered gods or just
like her because she's like the a number
one valkyrie i honestly think that
everybody in asgard is a god but like
the actual big gods like there's like
gods and then there's like senior gods
like your orders and your thor's and
your your hellas
have to have way more cosmic energy than
uh your because i feel like your regular
your joe schmo
as guardian citizen could absolutely
destroy anybody on earth because like
they're just they're just really strong
right
yeah i guess
but unless they come down and do that
the earthling has no idea about them
they don't know right you know jack
bryce as guardian i don't know about
that right
he's not a god jack bryce as a guardian
he wouldn't get killed in the wish but
if jack bryce as guardian started coming
to earth and been like worship me and
like picking up cars and like you know
walking on water or some some some
nonsense like that then people would be
like oh i guess he's a god and then he
would get wiped out by this curse
right if that if that were to happen so
we'll say valkyrie's a god but not
everyone in asgard um yeah no more
idiots so that's the end of like moon
knight and all the other avatars on
earth that could be on earth however
even without a bast there would still be
a black panther because the heart-shaped
herb is what gives black panthers powers
and that would still exist i think
that's right yeah but there would be no
more great protector which is quite sad
because i liked going to dragon land in
shanghai um it was very nice and this
also probably kills evil beings like the
dweller in darkness which is great and
mephisto and nightmare so uh that's a
great little thing because like they're
sort of yeah you get rid of good gods
but you also get rid of like the bad
gods too so that's probably good like a
demon's just a bad god at the end of the
day so
basically basically but this also brings
up the issue of afterlifes do they all
fall apart without gods because the
afterlifes are different realms so they
might be able to exist without the gods
but you know people's souls have to go
somewhere and there would be no gods to
protect the realms much like how odin
kept the nine realms safe but in theory
the master of the mystic arts could
protect earth from other realms but this
also brings up the question if no new
gods could exist after gore's witch
because if a bunch of people got
together and started worshiping someone
would they now become a new god and like
all this godly magic and cosmic power
has got to go somewhere okay
okay so let's think about it okay first
the afterlife's right the afterlife
probably still exist maybe these gods
created them but even if you if they're
created and there's like souls there
like valhalla or whatever and you kill
the gods that play still has to exist
right
uh right but then for something like the
do what in the field of reeds you have a
towerette like weighing hearts and stuff
or you have like anubis weighing hearts
if they're gone do people just like go
in immediately
i mean someone has to like take over
right because like all this cosmic power
so if you kill the gods we talked about
like cosmic power you kill the gods the
power still exists right in the theory
that
you know energy can't just like go away
it has to be put somewhere right all if
someone just like shows up if the next
person who dies and they show up in
their afterlife and they're like this is
mine now i'm taking it but
does that make them a god do they feel
like a vacuum
i mean if you own a natural life i guess
that makes you a god i would assume so
so or maybe the people just like hang
out there and there is no ownership it's
like a commune and everyone's just dead
together
it's real it's free real estate it's
free real estate
yeah it's hard to think about because
like someone's got to control these
afterlifes so i think people just like
start showing up in afterlife's kind of
willy-nilly there's no organization to
it so maybe even if you're a norse if
you're an asgardian and you die you
don't wind up in valhalla you wind up in
like the duat and you're like what's
going on i don't i didn't follow this
uh i don't know the rules here what are
the rules i mean like yeah if all the
gods die like what if like if some like
sometime in the past like all the gods
got together and like divvied up the
little like afterlife realms like all
right this little area is yours and like
you know and this area's mines but like
if all of them are gone then like
anybody could show up anywhere and be
like oh [ __ ] right this is just
unclaimed land right so i guess i'll
take it and become a god but that
doesn't make that a bad thing that
doesn't make that a bad thing empty
because we're we're talking as an
oppressed people these gods are keeping
us down and they're telling us like no
you need us you need us guides here to
keep you all safe but if we get rid of
them it's gonna be chaos so don't get
rid of us but i think we should get rid
of them let the chaos reign let's get
those things figured out chaos
but that other point you brought up mt
could could you make a new gut like does
gore's wish mean no gods can ever exist
or does it just kind of like wipe the
slate clean and if people want to start
worshiping something they can or like
the second you start getting worshipped
to just die because you're like no no
don't make me a guy don't make me god
realistically it would probably just
cover all the gods that were present at
the time of the wish much like you know
thanos to snap er raised half of like
life on earth like that didn't mean that
more life couldn't be made yeah yeah
yeah so it's just like a really it's
like a hard reset that's what he's gonna
say it's happening it's like okay yeah
it's like all right all the the godhood
of the universe is corrupt so let's just
get rid of it and if more gods show up
in the future then so be it but like you
know let's just try universe without
gods it's basically doors going forward
if a new god shows up we'll remind him
like hey you have this thing we got rich
mom so you better be good you better be
a good guy
this is what happens to you look at this
this graveyard full of gods
watching you
that'd be amazing yeah everything that
would be happening on earth with its
gods would also be happening on every
other planet with gods and while earth
might not have a lot of followers for
its gods some of the other more devout
planets might have issues with their
gods suddenly disappearing this could
lead to some intergalactic wars as
planets try to cope with the sudden
disappearance of their gods which is and
we see sort of see i sort of like a
little bit of that happening in thor
four with um king yakon in like um at
the beginning of the movie with the
guardians it's like yo something
happened to our gods
i don't know if i'm misremembering that
i had to go to the bathroom during that
part
like not protecting the temple and now
these owls have taken over the temple
they're like where are our gods and i'm
protecting things so yeah unless they
knew about gore and his mission they
would be totally in the dark about what
just happened yeah there would totally
be some planets where they're like our
gods dead we're gonna go kill another
planet now and they would basically
someone had to explain to them like no
there was this guy gore he was doing
this whole thing it makes me think about
the snap right there were these planets
where the snap happens they don't know
what the snap is they don't know who
thanos is they're just going about their
day and also in half the planet just
dusts away and they're like
uh and then like five years later half
of them come back and they're like what
happened they have no idea what happened
unless someone from nova showed up and
told them what happened uh like they
have no idea what's going on it's like
that episode of rick and morty where
they're like i guess we you know we
should believe in the floating head
right because that's a thing
we should tie balloons to ourselves it's
like people would just be making up
things so you would have these like war
planets who were like someone killed our
god so we're going out there to kill
everybody and you have to explain that
i'm like no no no this is someone made a
wish you're fine it happened to
everybody don't
don't get crazy about it but this would
cause a lot of chaos like people oh
[ __ ] i've never really thought about
that like like some some planet that
like has no connection to other any
other planet it's like wow yeah my wife
and kids are all gone and like they have
like a whole new family that they come
back five years later yeah it's like
what is going on
they have no explanation to what's going
on so yeah zero they're god's suddenly
dead and they're like i guess we should
just go kill other planets i don't know
right god's gone what do we do now
trying to think like if there's any
marvel alien race that might be
triggered i mean i will always say the
cree because the cree everything sets
them off no matter what oh yeah the cree
are the weirdest and like honestly like
the supreme intelligence is basically
like a god and like the actual you know
the supreme intelligence is essentially
an mcu afterlife because like that's
where all the pre-consciousness goes
right
at the end of their lives like so do you
think if gore
if gore succeeded would that kill the
supreme intelligence you think because i
would say the cree worship the supreme
intelligence yeah it's their god i think
that's a good point
yeah i think yeah but i would say the
supreme intelligence will go because
like that is a god in itself it's just
like
you're not a computer effective you're
dead
you ain't safe you ain't safe you're
weirdo you ain't safe mind sweeper
you're dead you're dead
but yeah i know like oh man i really
would like to see what i hope what if
season two goes into what if gork
succeeded because like it was a freebie
there's a free one for you kevin you
write it down
right here
for you guys geez give me a give us a
credit there's a story by credit come on
kevin come on
we'll also take some of that sweet
marvel green if you know what i'll take
some money
but we also got to talk about the extra
dimensional gods because moving up the
god food chain a little bit we we have
these extra dimensional types of beings
and there would also be the gods that
aren't necessarily tied to a single
planet and move a little bit more freely
about the universe and we mentioned him
earlier but this would be an entity like
dormammu ruling over the dark dimension
or even mephisto ruling over the hell
lords or schumer gorath an ancient demon
who has ruled over many dimensions a
little one eyeballed um little demon
like sort of like we saw in a multiverse
of madness
i can't wait to see more tentacle boys
and doctor strange three whoo i was
really sad when that uh eyeball i got
what's his name
like garganto's gargan died i was like
he was just being used you just took his
eyes
jerks but any of these extra dimensional
beings that could be considered a god
would be wiped out and perhaps the
biggest threat to them being gone would
be their dimension careening out of
control like for example without
dormammu would the dark dimensions still
try and consume other wolves that is a
good question mt
i think
i think it probably would i think the
nature of the dark dimension is it wants
to absorb
life right it wants to absorb the light
uh and dormammu just kind of steers the
ship a little bit but if you kill
dormammu
i think if he's wiped out the dark
dimension still exists like that energy
still exists it's probably just gonna
keep spreading right just a little less
a little more chaotically right i think
that um the point of dormammu was that
duran was supposed to be the only
consciousness
within the uh in within the dark
dimension which is why
when k celius was going to go um into
the dark dimensions like you got to be
part of the one like there is no
individuality here it's like it's
dormammu or nothing baby like there is
no like there doesn't seem to be any
um anybody else or at least a lot of
other people because we know that um
clea seems to be native yeah she loves
you there right so like there aren't a
whole lot of other people there so like
maybe if your mom was gone like there's
just a slot left was like hey we have
all this energy all this dark power who
wants to be the next door bamboo
yeah it could be you clear you need
mephisto kind of ruling over the dream
dimension and like keeping it in check
even though they're doing bad things
every now and then they do some bad
things they're doing some good they are
controlling these dimensions like
schumacher kind of lives in whatever
dimension he wants to live in he can die
he's just taken over wipe him out but
yeah some of these
you know i hate to say you need them
there you need them they're doing the
work uh and yes a few billion souls have
to perish whatever that's life sorry
yeah all right and i feel like you're
messing things up here
no i but i feel like you know like you
said like they could be playing a cosmic
role in keeping the darkness from
consuming other universes like we know
that um in multiverse of madness we got
the introduction of the incursions and
so like i'm sure that these dark beings
probably don't want the end of the
multiverse because that would include
them in a way because like hey we're
darks but like we're also a crucial part
of this universe so the end of this
universe through the incursions and
secret wars and all that not the best
thing so like we are doing our part to
make sure that uh dormammu doesn't
actually succeed and uh go into other
universes um but yeah no it's uh i feel
like we haven't really explored the dark
role of the dark gods of the mcu yet
yeah and so it'd be really interesting
to see if if gore succeeded and killed
them all because i feel like things
would just go completely out of whack
yeah it would be great i know we're
talking about what if he succeeded but
he did kill some gods right he did kill
some right thor love and thunder i feel
like
more gods than gore did i know right
that we saw on screen that we saw yeah
we saw the stream but it would be funny
as we keep going through like phase four
and on and like the mcu if there's still
if it still gets brought up that like oh
yeah 10 years ago gore killed this god
and it's still affecting like the
problems that were happening right now
right especially if he killed some like
dark dimension type gods and like their
stuff is just spilling out into the
cosmos now it's like ah gore killed this
guy now we gotta deal with this dude i
would love i mean this would never
happen i don't think gore's not this
strong but like if gore
killed galactus like a long time ago
that would be such a fun way of like
explaining why galactus wasn't around
but like i i think that galactus is
still being set up but like it'd be
really fun
it's a big universe empty he just hasn't
made it to our little pocket yet he's
out right considering his way he's just
munching he's on a
but let's talk about the cosmic gods
because as we keep moving up the godly
food chain there's also the cosmic gods
out there that also could be destroyed
by gore's wish this would of course
include the celestials and they would be
all wiped out in our universe which
depending on how you view the celestials
might be a good thing uh that could be
good because i'd be good i don't think
that this would eliminate the eternals
though because many of them were often
confused for actual gods because you
could say that like some of them were
worshipped like athena was worshipped
but there is an actual athena and like
right so maybe by by the rules of this
wish like all the eternals would be
spared even though they got confused for
god's all the time they'd be like well
you weren't actually the god so you're
fine uh but yeah the celestials they're
gone they're gone for sure the eternals
have to fill out a form to gore just be
like i'm not actually a god please
actually god i'm just a robot oh my god
jack this way please thank you thank you
so much thank you
with you celestial's god this might mean
an end to the creation of new galaxies
in our universe and that could be a
problem down the line many millennia
from now but for the immediate time
being you know no real big problem plus
you know no more emergencies which is
great it's great for all the people that
live on planets because they don't want
to kill the specials boom gone no
problem
wipe them out wipe them out baby
[Laughter]
though the celestials do exist outside
of the multiverse this would definitely
put an end to them within the mcu 616
universe but would they be able to be
reborn in the mcu at some point because
we have talked about this mt how this
the celestials exist like outside the
multiverse right they created it uh
right and they kind of project their
avatar into our multiverse but even if
you kill
like you know uh
or some uh
what a person no
uh that airstream aeroshem yeah even if
you kill like the arishem in the 616 he
still exists outside of it and he just
has to go
okay and like reproject himself in so
like i think you can wipe out the
celestials
all of them within the mcu and even in
marvel comics like one celestial has
been able to like recreate all the other
ones right so you wipe them all out but
i think eventually they would like
reproject into our they'd realize they'd
been killed in our universe and be like
hold on a second wait guys we need to go
back to the 616 we've been wiped out
there let's all get together let's do
the ham thing let's spin some galaxies
let's get back in there uh i think they
would eventually show back up again
right right because like um we learned
from eternals that the celestials are
actually um they run on a billion year
cycle because like ericsson says every
billion years celestials are born and
like we've seen from eternals that
airship himself looks kind of old he
looks like he's crying crumbling apart
and like he's he's got some dry skin for
sure yeah he's not looking too hot so i
think that you know even if all the
celestials were killed like they knew
that they like their lives aren't
infinite i feel like in my opinion and
that like all the the babies inside of
every planet will eventually become
celestials because like eventually
there's going to be a certain point
where humanity hits the amount of energy
that they need to emerge so like even if
the celestials died
with the babies in them also die i guess
i just think the the little seeds inside
the planet if gore's successful rank the
little six well that's a good point
empty because they're not gods yet
they're just little right so
maybe there still would be emergencies
because they just they don't get worship
they just get like life energy so yeah
maybe you wipe out the celestials
and then the eternals don't know what to
do because their boss is dead and
they're like i guess we just hang out on
this planet they never get told about
the emergence and then yeah maybe the
emergencies still happen
so i think all of the celestials there
aren't a celestial who's not a god so i
think even those life seeds would be
like wiped out
you know what i mean i think they would
get wiped out too
i don't think doris thought this through
i don't know he hasn't thought it
through he's just angry he's just
limiting his emotions like come on
gordon think about it think about it we
need the celestials come on man
i don't know i don't know if we need
them
i mean constant cosmic genocide come on
think with your brain
yeah there's also cosmic beings like
galactus that could potentially be wiped
out and he controls the very powerful
power cosmic and which without a
galactus controlling it would just be
flowing around in the universe yeah
quite dangerous like you have all those
there's a lot of cosmic beings right you
know they're all over comics and they
all get wiped out and they kind of work
as like
uh
the engine of the universe right like
right galactus is consuming old galaxies
like he keeps balance in the in the mcu
yeah it's all power balance so you kill
galactus galactus was like the last
living man from the previous universe mr
gallon he gets the power cosmic uh and
he's eating so now he's gone because
he's definitely a god he's a big g god
right he's dead so now all that power
cosmic yeah i think it's just flowing
around kind of like the phoenix force
and whatever it's gonna just find a new
person and make them galactus i think
probably you can't kill the power cosmic
like gore wasn't wiping out the power of
the universe he was wiping out the gods
so yeah right kill galactus but there's
going to be a new galactus
exactly because like galactus was
basically made from the like the
combined i believe the combined energies
of like the next big bang um like yeah
right he was at the end of his universe
and so he basically went into the big
bang and like he got all that energy so
like if he just died all the energy like
you said has to go out somewhere so
somebody's going to become another
galactus yeah um because i just feel
like yeah people are just doomed to like
absorb this energy and be changed in
different ways that's sort of the story
of the marvel universe um oh man it's so
interesting to talk about um and then
there's also the watchers which would
also be wiped out as well and though
they just watched so they might not
necessarily be all that missed but of
course a bunch of other random cosmic
gods like the builders the elders of the
universe the stranger the hawk god all
god um and we know that from uh
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 that
stakar is
an mcu character and in the comics he is
basically the avatar of the hot god like
um we just said um so that's probably a
factor that that might could be a factor
in not guarding the galaxy vol 3 which
i'm very excited for but yeah um the
elders of the universe the builders
which were teased in guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 with um like there's
builder machine code all over the uh the
yellow ship that they used to destroy
egos for so like the builders do exist
in the mcu um so yeah like
i'm just wondering
what that whole domino effect would be
this is because
they're huge in the universe yeah yeah a
lot of those elder gods like they've
kind of done the work already right like
the universe has been built and now
they're just kind of existing
uh so i guess if they get wiped out no
big deal yeah the watchers getting wiped
out is interesting because
they're kind of watching what's going on
but uh
if there's no like big gods to kind of
screw things up then like they don't
need to be watching and keeping track of
everything because it's like oh well if
the big gods are gone who cares like
so i'll figure itself out so yeah we'd
miss the watchers but that's just
because we missed we like what if and we
won't have whatever the watchers are
gone
we just don't know what's going on in
the multiverse but yeah a lot of these a
lot of these big gods behind the scenes
you might not notice it at first but for
like the long tail of the universe it
would be bad if they suddenly
disappeared yeah i mean like maybe not
the elderly universe because like
they're they've they're pretty much
selfish people so like they're just
doing their own hobbies but let's move
up another tier to the abstract gods of
the mcu and these would be the ultra
powerful forces in the cosmos that cover
abstract ideas and we're talking about
death oblivion infinity and even mr
eternity himself we saw in for love and
thunder meditating like a weird
like a man who just likes meditation i
like meditation it's great um in theory
the whole universe is
legit legit the whole universe um in
theory these forces keep some sort of
semblance of balance in the universe so
could they be wiped out by war's wish
and would eternity just like you know
off himself and like is this even
possible
yeah i don't know i think these guys
might be too big right you have to have
like the concept of death
and infinity and eternity
like i don't know if you could just wipe
them out because
the universe still needs life and death
it needs like growth and entropy so like
you can't just like wipe it all out and
i don't think eternity would be like oh
okay i'll just kill myself get out of
here gore you idiot that's probably what
eternity would say
are you seeing that
i think it's more than the boogie man
yeah way better than the boogie man
sorry that was the veggietales reference
um i don't know
[Laughter]
i don't know your evangelical veggie
tales nonsense that might be probably
all my other uh the church kids know
what i'm talking about
[Music]
he's bigger than godzilla or the
monsters on tv sorry i'm done the
boogeyman is real kids and he'll get you
oh he'll get you the boogeyman is gore
uh yeah i don't know because like
[Music]
i don't think eternity would like fall
for that he'd just be like no i killed
the all the gods beneath me and my pals
but
no you can't kill me because eternity is
the universe you can't like kill it
right like i don't think that eternity
would eternity has its best interests at
heart like at the end of the day all
life in the universe has its best
interests at heart and it will you know
do whatever it takes to defend itself so
i think the trinity will do
pretty much anything but that
anything but i think this is where turns
like i can't kill death yeah infinity
and oblivion i can't kill all that but
kill everything else for you my my man
we'll make a deal here i'll make a deal
with you gore right let's strike a deal
make a deal
um let's get howie mandel here let's get
the banker here
deal or no deal um all right we've made
it to the very top of the god pile so
let's talk about a couple of heavy
hitters here and there's the living
tribunal of course who is the cosmic
entity that oversees all of the
multiverses making sure they stay in
balance and no one universe becomes too
powerful is this being too big for
gore's wrath yeah i don't think gore
gets to kill the living tribunal because
the yeah they're above like the
they oversee the multiverses there's no
way there's no way
there's no way
yeah i feel like all the gores need to
be working all the courses of the
multiverse need to be working in tandem
to go get all the cores make the wish at
the same time
then maybe i'll allow it yeah but like
yeah it's too much way too much then we
also have the fulcrum which is what the
celestials and the watchers all worship
or follow and basically the embodiment
of the consciousness of the one above
all and speaking of we should include
the one above all and this is the very
top of the mcu's god hierarchy often
portrayed by stan lee or jack kirby or
in the instance of the mcu you could
also include kevin feige it's like are
they safe from gore i mean here's a wild
thought empty
we know we lost our boy stan lee we lost
him right
was that was that gore
was that gore making it to eternity
kill all the gods
and then our stanley drops dead because
gore made it to eternity
did gore kill stan lee
did he do it
oh my god
i mean canonically that would be very
weird at the mcu stanley's just walking
down the street
gore makes it to eternity and like all
the gods gotta die and then stanley's
like
and then just like dies
that's how i mean he's the watcher
so like he is a god but like i highly
doubt the mcu would go around i'm just
saying did the police look into gore for
the death
that's all i'm asking
seriously uh that's his biggest crime if
that's if true um in one version of the
multiverse gore makes it and kills
stanley that's all i'm saying that's how
dare you gore my god that i never
actually thought about that because like
yeah that would include stan lee cause
stan lee's a god and the mcu he is the
god oh
wow in some in one universe in the
multiverse stan lee gets murdered by
gore i've never actually thought about
that that is hardcore [ __ ] uh that's how
it happens someone update the wikipedia
right now cause of death gore gore um
but yeah no speaking of the one above
all um this is again not to be confused
with the other one above all that we
just saw introduced in 4-4 who is a
celestial with the same name which is
very weird um like one of the statues
almost fall on the kids and then uh thor
grabs it he's like oh not today here's
my power kids um so yeah this is like
the the real one above all the one the
biggest the head honcho um he can
definitely be he's totally safe like
there's no way totally you would be
affected because they control eternity
and they'd be like no no no yeah no no
but that ain't happening
so this is just a small look at all the
consequences of gore's plan if it were
successful and while many agreed with
gore after seeing thor loving the
thunder do you think that he was still
in the right here uh i mean he's got a
good heart
he's got the right idea a lot of these
guys people underneath all that darkness
there is a good one there i think a lot
of the gods are problematic we should
wipe out a fair amount of them but i
think just throwing a full blanket kill
all the gods i don't think it's fair
it's not a good idea i think we've shown
it's a little messy i think his original
plan is fine going one by one
door-to-door taking out the bad guys
that's fine by me we can't just wipe
everything out cause again it's gonna
create this like power and balance the
wrong people are gonna get the cosmic
power it'll just create more problems
than we than we could deal with right
now
so i think you know i was on gore's side
a lot of this movie but like you know i
think is the ultimate plan of making it
to eternity while it's smart great hack
great cheat code
not a good idea not a good idea at all
yeah we need something we need some
balance going on as an oppressed person
uh underneath the boot of all these gods
here i am kissing it saying please stay
gods i can't believe i'm saying this
geez but yeah
i can't believe myself right now
i do think that gore had a lot of like
really legitimate grievances i think
that he should have just like really
specifically tailored which gods that he
murdered like only the bad ones the lazy
ones maybe um the ones that like clearly
don't give a [ __ ] about people go to
town but like you know you're nice gods
like thor and like jane just leave them
be like they clearly give up like
literally one of them's on the avengers
like come on man like give him give him
a break gore not right in his actions
but like we definitely see where you're
coming from because uh we see where god
sometimes they just they just don't hear
us in if you're god
for sure your god really sucked and
deserved to die
the gore's god especially deserve to die
you deserve that uh
i i was actually quite happy uh but
anyway um
you know what's also godly new
rockstarsmerch.com
and
capitalism
so yeah be sure to head on over to new
rockstars.com to check out our newest
latest obsession shirt inspired by thor
11 thunder called worthy of love the
shirt is limited edition and once it's
gone it's gone forever so check out all
of our awesome merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com it's a great way to
support the channel and a great way to
look good while doing it because like
you gotta multitask i mean you're you're
a multitasker come on yeah such a good
multiple person
would look so good in our shirts just
saying lilu dallas multitask seriously
mt stands for multitask i do it terribly
um and before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the
people to help bring big question to you
people like avast iron do you worry
about this i don't know why i just argue
cause like i've asked me is that this is
a pirate term
i think that's a very modern
pirate
that we've ascribed to the pirates i
don't know if they ever said a vast i of
us i don't know um i don't have a lot of
pirate friends but hey do you worry
about the many nefarious forces out
there looking to get a piece of your
computer well a avast is a global leader
in cyber protection for more than 30
years entrusted by over get this
435 million users and prevents over 1.5
billion attacks every single month a
vast new all-in-one solution of vast one
helps you take control of your safety
and privacy online through a range of
features a vast one is their best
protection yet giving you everything you
need to control your safety and privacy
online and accessible through a single
easy-to-use interface a vast multitude
of features provides you with privacy
and security as you scour the web and
even help with your machine's
performance i like the award-winning
antivirus that stops viruses and malware
from harming your devices as well as its
data breach monitoring that will alert
you if your online accounts have been
compromised plus you can feel confident
using public wi-fi when you're out there
in the wild thanks to their firewall
protection which keeps your personal
information secure and prevents others
from trying to access your computer and
steal all of your precious data so
thanks to avast for supporting big
question confidently take control of
your online world with a vast one it
helps you stay safe from viruses
phishing attacks ransomware hacking
attempts and other cyber crimes learn
more about avast one at avast.com and
thanks again to avast for sponsoring big
question we love you but now it is time
for our bite size questions are you
ready mr brandon uh i think i'm ready
let me just oh there's one grab
something
delicious wow we have another
question from crispy chrissy always with
the best questions thank you crispy
chrissy
now brandon it be would it have been
possible for thanos to also get dusted
when he snapped his fingers or is the
person snapping immune
crispy chrissy thank you
yes good question well there are a
couple things to consider here okay
thanos was a big stats guy he loves
statistics all right he didn't really
hold out a grudge okay he wasn't there
for a grudge he just wanted to wipe out
half of the life in the universe
randomly no hard feelings guys this is
just business okay he didn't care if it
was his enemies or his friends remember
when he was beating the crap out of tony
stark and he's like i hope they remember
you bye and he just leaves he could have
killed him he's like i'm gonna do a snap
you might die anyways who cares right he
let the random number generator of the
infinity stones decide okay he doesn't
care who dies he just wants to get his
job done with that in mind it would seem
like he would be willing to die for his
cause too when he does the snap in
infinity war he immediately goes to the
soul stone death puddle all right he
looks at his hand he sees like the
gauntlet's gone it's not on his hand he
talks to a young gamora and he's
probably like yeah i'm pretty dead he
probably thought in that moment i
snapped i did it i'm dead great problem
solved awesome and then he like snaps
back right well it doesn't snap back he
comes back he's back into thor's
beautiful arms uh and he looks down and
his he's got the burnt gauntlet on his
hand and he's like oh and he like looks
surprised
yeah he's like i'm alive
this sucks
and he's like oh
i'm still here oh no i'm still here
this sucks what did i do
and then like he immediately
yeah he's like he's like uh and then he
like eats out of there right and he goes
to his farm planet uh and he's like cool
thank god i got out of there okay now if
it were truly random and we got to
consider this too okay if it was truly
random if he's just like in his mind he
does the snap and he's like wipe out
half the life in the universe
and he is like the last titan left alive
right he's the last person of titan left
alive because everyone else from titan
is dead
uh
and it would be weird for his little
like infinity stone spell to wipe him
out if he's if if his little spell in
his mind was like wipe out half of all
life based on species because if he's
like half all life in the universe it
might not affect species
and different planets equally right
right uh but in his mind he was probably
like wipe out half half the life on
every planet so then if he's the last
titan then the stats i think are in his
favor and not get wiped out
maybe i don't know i don't know how that
works
well like him in him and arrows are the
last titans basically
oh that's true i guess arrows is still
alive so he could have killed his
brother in this in this it would it
would have been brutal i don't know if
he knows if pharos is still alive i
don't know
it's risky it's risky for him
but but empty we also know that part of
this like little snap spell that you do
is thinking about what you want because
when tony is prepping smart hulk to do
to undo the snap he reminds bruce to
bring back everyone but did not change
anything from the last five years
because him and pepper had sex and they
had a baby
so he's like don't undo that uh so it's
possible that this wimp this coward
thanos could have been preventing his
demise with a little mental caveat when
he did his cute little snap he was like
wipe out half the life in the universe
but keep me alive please i don't want to
die
but i like to think that thanos was a
true zealot and was willing to die for
his cause so yeah i think he was rolling
the dice here i think he could have died
i don't think he would have prevented
his own death he wanted he wanted to die
he wanted to wipe out the universe he
wanted to be on his farm which you know
when you buy the farm it's a metaphor
for dying he wanted to die but he lived
and he was like well i guess i guess i'm
living with the consequences of my own
actions oh boy any guys get chopped off
whoops that's how it goes
whoopsie-doopsie
[Laughter]
not so grateful this universe i guess
but i like that answer brandon i i
personally think that uh thanos is just
too selfish and like he's like you know
what you could be a retired farm
please
i think he purposely was like yeah i'm
gonna save myself because like i'm the
only one all right to save the universe
just in case this happens again i need
to be around to do it again you know
okay um so but you know i think in true
in true thanos fashion we can be split
on this answer just like
the lives of the universe
we can be true
balanced perfectly like a little knife
like all things should be not brandon i
got another question for you to keep
things balanced hit me up one more one
and two um how does gravity on starships
work in the star wars universe oh boy
this is a good one this one this has
bothered me a little bit especially
watching like some obi-wan and like
thinking about star wars because most
hard sci-fi fans love to point out the
inconsistencies with true science and
physics problems that are just sort of
washed over and some lighter science
fiction works you know i think star wars
is more fantasy than
science fiction but you know it's a
story for another day right
uh right the gravity issues in star wars
are never really addressed you know they
just kind of get on ships and they fly
away and no one ever talks about it uh
so they're pretty much tackled in that
universe uh
star wars
the story itself it happened a long time
ago in a galaxy far far away but they
still have to deal with gravity and
creating artificial gravity in this
universe we know this uh like in the
clone wars series little clone troopers
they had to have magnets on their boots
so they could stick to the ship when
they were in zero gravity uh but for
most of the story by the time we as the
audience come in they've worked out a
lot of the kinks because science has
been going on there for a long time
they've worked out a lot of the problems
us normal
humans have to deal with
they have artificial gravity generators
to
of course create artificial gravity
within the star wars universe uh this
technology is mostly used a lot on
starships uh when they're on when
they're on a planet's surface they use
repulsor lifts uh to push against a
planet's natural gravity right we've
seen this tech used in everything from
like chairs and podiums the senate right
and even starships they use repulsor
lift technology when they're on it when
they're on a planet or something that
generates its own gravity they can like
push against it that's how they are able
to float like that uh they also use
acceleration compensators also known as
inertia dampeners uh as as the tech used
on modern starships to protect the crew
and passengers when traveling in and out
of hyperspace and radically changing
speeds basically
the the problem's been solved that's
star wars for you baby they're like we
figured this out hundreds of years ago
you don't have to ask about it because
in reality all of these aliens from
different planets would have like
different gravity needs based on the
gravity in their own planet i mean this
is something that the expanse gets into
a lot uh so it's just kind of wacky that
everywhere you go in star wars gravity
is not a problem don't ask about it it's
handled uh that's that's that's sci-fi
fantasy for you just kind of handled i
feel like i have an answer but they
don't they don't even really explain how
it all works necessarily because every
species would have its own needs but
it's just kind of fixed and the universe
has got along without it maybe you can
say that like they've had artificial
gravity for so long in star wars that
all of the aliens have adapted to it and
evolved with it
so it's fine the end
basically i feel like star wars is one
of those like you know beloved and like
franchises that have been around for so
long that like they get like those
science questions it's like they just
answer
guardians they all had
translators that worked and every
alien's got it but then they're on earth
and people don't have translators but
you know what it's fine who cares
we just gotta get through the movie okay
don't ask all these questions
like just enjoy fiction geez just enjoy
it
just enjoy the story
but now it is part four as a part of the
show that i personally enjoy a lot it's
time for the box of scraps
[Laughter]
now brandon if you could replace one
godly or cosmic entity in the mcu which
one would you choose to take their place
and why
you know which one would you choose
yeah i mean you want to be like a good
god you don't want to be like a bad guy
not like a fun god
fun god situation
i mean odin seemed to have like a pretty
good go but he was in his like
retirement years you know what i mean
early on it was a lot of work a lot of
fighting
a lot of battles and stuff like that
uh
yeah i mean
uh the olympians seem to have it like
really worked out i know
he's got the orgies going so i just got
my heart
chilling out like zeus is a pretty good
spot to take i would i think
zeus is pretty high up there
or like one of the aeneid
they seem to be pretty chill they're
hanging out you know in their own little
place they don't even come to earth
anymore
they just kind of hang out and do their
thing
that would be pretty fun
yeah
i mean i think you got to go zeus right
this has been you gotta go zeus i mean
like zeus is a terrible person but he's
chilling man he's just chilling chilly's
hanging out
he's got kids
hanging out
and like we're just people but
if me and you were zeus we would just
have to find a good balance it's like
yeah yeah i'd be a really nice zeus i'd
be very chill right i'd be very chill if
you threw a lightning bolt through me
and i survived i wouldn't be mad i'd let
it go i'd let it go
exactly
um i would either choose zeus or uh
kanchu because i do like conscious whole
vibe he's a very chill dude and so like
i would i would become a
children he's a chill dude you think
she's like a chill dude he's not a chill
dude but like can't you he's like i
don't know
he's that old guy at the park like
yelling at a tree or something like that
like you gotta worry about kashu he's a
little true
he's seen too much he's seen too much
he has seen way too much um he has a too
much hate in his heart um phillip
vengeance so i would be a less vengeful
version of konchu okay i'll allow that
totally
but yes i would use either zeus or cod
shoot because those are the two
gods that i saw
but that is it for this episode of big
question thank you as always to
off-screen producer brandon for joining
me on this episode follow him at grin
and barrack to see him tweet some
amazing things and just to support him
because he's an amazing man um follow me
at mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] most importantly
follow the new rockstars here on youtube
and all other social media platforms
make sure to hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video and if you have big
questions of your own to submit to us
share them on our new rockstars discord
server just be sure that you are 18
years old or over and interested and you
just click the link below in the
description or just search us on discord
to join the conversation and yeah thank
you guys so much for watching we love
you guys so much we appreciate the time
that you guys take with us every single
week and we'll see you guys next time
bye
bye
see ya
[Music]
you
[Music]